atene ragazzi perfetto e non mi devo far
vedere come ci sono arrivato a questo
punto perché non è stato così semplice
per 3 3 tra un attimo della a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono fa vj e oggi siamo in un nuovo blog
in un nuovo flop
ok privo di far vedere la cella in
ragazzi come al solito inizia regola
phone arte la settimana rega che questa
settimana è stata l'intera non sono
affatto diversa frasi senza morire
comunque è stata vinta da valentina che
ha fatto staff a rate epica i ragazzi
volevo dirvi che agli ultimi anni non ho
fatto video perché per i mente ho avuto
il mal di gol e quindi mi sono preso un
attimino di pausa ovviamente ragazzi che
cosa ho fatto per farmi passare il mal
di gola fatto l'ice bike challenge
perché ovviamente chi lassina secchiata
piena di ghiaccio in testa è il modo
migliore per farsi passare il mal di
gola ragazzi i ragazzi arrivando ai
sbarchi e challenger cosa che volevo
puntualizzare che comunque l'ice bucket
challenge in verità non è un tormentone
tipo l'harlem sheikh dell'anno scorso ma
è diciamo un tormentone che è fatto per
fare beneficenza per la ricerca per la
sla e ovviamente ragazzi sarebbe di buon
senso non fare semplicemente i pirla
tirandosi una secchiata in testa ma
anche fare ciò per cui l'ice bike
challenge è stata creata quindi donare
per la per la ricerca per la sla come io
ho fatto ovviamente l'invito chiunque
anche se non fatela celle in gito
chiunque sia di chiunque possa farlo a
donare per la ricerca per la sla ragazzi
perché alla fine è una buonissima azione
detto questo ragazzi vi lascio alla xbox
challenge che credetemi che sarà
alquanto ridicolo
ve lo garantisco grazie prenda stacco
non valeva sono stortissimo no non posso
fare ora aspettano che oggi qui vorrei
sbarchi e challenge siccome non avevo il
ghiaccio normale ciò quello istantaneo
che si mette quando ti fai male però va
bene lo stesso comunque ringrazio
anzitutto mezzo mondo lady gaga urbana
per avermi nominato novino lord
voldemort o lui che non deve essere
nominato ma non nomino lo stesso nicchi
bocca e angelo duro e direi che possiamo
iniziare
sabato
ok freddo è decisamente freddo ma c'è un
motivo perché ho ancora fatico alla fine
ha detto questo ragazzino di passare
l'ultima news perché ma state chiedendo
praticamente tutti regala fine quindi
devo dirvelo molti di voi hanno visto la
pubblicità di mtv nel quale dicono che
io parteciperò al di mtv digital days
ed effettivamente ragazzi è così
partecipare agli mtv digital days sono
ragazzi sabato 13 settembre alle ore 16
alla reggia di venaria di torino dove si
svolgono a punto gli empi e digital days
voglio approfittare per la mente per
fare un raduno per parlare anche un po
con voi sarebbe di persona sarebbe
bellissimo quindi ne approfitto già che
ci sono ragazzi per chi vuole venire
tanto è gratuito cioè è una roba qui può
partecipare chiunque sarà una cosa
bellissima con che ci vediamo lì per chi
vuole venire io ci sarò in molti hanno
chiesto che cosa farò gli mtv digital de
sio di preciso non lo so ancora se devo
essere sincero voi sperate che non canti
per questo motivo
[Musica]
ne va mai live find someone like you
noi siamo lasciato molto bene detto
questo ragazzine che con le news abbiamo
finito dire che possiamo stare allo
scherzo dei pacchi ragazzi vi siete
superati perché ma ci sarà una volta che
non li faccio cadere porca trota ragazzi
vi siete superati perché avete inviato
un albero di natale dalla decorazione
nel parco sembra un albero di natale
quindi grazie a ripartire la più piccola
ragazza che a natale manca ancora un
pochettino che a quanto mi manca mi è
caduto sul testicolo destro
io non so che cos'è questa roba però è
una scatola nera e le scatole nere sono
sono brutte a prescindere video ghazi la
la scatola nera non ho idea di che cosa
possa contenere ma mi fa paura il
pensiero quindi la pro subito ragazzi ho
trovato un koala e bellissimo si chiama
ciuffo
una nutella ragazzi che c'è scritto fa
vj però la cosa mi preme che mi sembra
un tantino scaduta st nutella a
giudicare dal dal bianco che c'è dentro
però grazie grazie mille
nemmeno mio cane non aveva ragazzi la
scritta lorenzo sul palco vince tutto
sei un genio c'è una paura tremenda di
trovarci cose sa cos'è giudicate voi
macos esso cocco perché ci sono passati
non sono patatine ma sembrano patatina
questi ragazzi ho trovato un mare di
patatine che non so come mai però grazie
molto gentili e poi ho trovato questo mi
sa che ho messo su un po di chili però
perché non me lo ricordavo così però è
figo ragazzi basta è il mio nuovo idolo
caso chiuso e dopodiché ragazzino hanno
inviato questo che sarebbe tipo un credo
sia un'alternativa alla nutella lo fosse
non hanno capito ragazzi che sono
innamorato di una cosa sola e non posso
aver amanti quindi detto questo di
ripassare all'ultimo patto che è quello
di natale a guardare i miliardi di
giornali che trovo io sono più
aggiornato di un reporter comunque è una
cosa kick ass
cosa diavolo est affidata io nuzzo
ragazzi chi è che me l'ha mandato prof
siete peggio è bellissimo grazie imitato
c'è anche un c'è questo dietro 890 6.771
inscritti mi sa che era da un po che
doveva aprire il suo pacco però grazie
di cuore e quindi lega dire che possiamo
passare al fa vi risponda prima domanda
ragazze rivela badly e local sfami
risponde perché sei fissato così tanto
con la nutella in realtà e non è che
sono fissato con la nutella soprattutto
quella variata riferì asta cos'è la
nutella è nata una capri mentre l'altra
quando ho aperto il canale più o meno
perché come se fosse casa mia
traquillamente dov'è la nutella
da quel momento ragazzi dalla frase dove
la nutella l'ho usata sempre tipo slogan
una roba del genere perché è piaciuto e
mi piaceva chiave a 100 mega adesso mi
fa schifo la nutella ripeto ma perché
c'è ancora sto schifo su attivano i vari
risponde fa ejei che poi allora io devo
ancora capire perché cazzo mi scrivono
fa vj favi jake cosa rappresentava la j
maiuscola ancora non l'ho capito come se
io ti può iscriversi giuseppe però con
la e maiuscola non ha senso cut pro
vabbè poi risponde fa vincere
come ti senti per il digital tv mi sento
pronto e già one iq un utente google si
ma famigerato sei amico mio nuovo idolo
sappilo fa vi risponde allora siccome
tipo nell'ultimo luogo messo messo
questa mi avevano fatto sto commento
adesso mi sono uscito anche con fare il
trofei miss longa la mandibola prova poi
risponde i tuoi profess professori
professori hanno visto o o tuoi video se
sì come hanno reagito amico mio io non
so come hanno reagito ai miei video però
so come reagirebbero tuo italiano questo
è sicuro su questo ragazzino è che posso
concludere qui con il blogger scusatemi
ancora sapevo la voce un po strano
perché ancora al mal di gola
spero mi passerà presto adesso mandati
darmi un'altra secchiata per finire vi
lascio con la fabi domanda me ne sono
ricordato ed è un miracolo
la domanda ragazzi e nei blog che cosa
mi ha ferito di più fa vi risponde lo
scarta già dei pacchi una lei due quindi
ragazzino è che posso concludere qui
servito è piaciuto ma solito lasciato
momento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook come non i video trovata una
descrizione solo se vorresti destinate
lirici di diano prossimo vi dove da
ragazzi